اتحدث اليوم عن مفهوم السياده الجديد الذي
لا يقل اهميه عن السياده العسكريه للدول
السياده على خطوط الانترنت في قاع
المحيطات والبحار شركات عمالقه
التكنولوجيا الامريكيه غيرت صناعه نقل
المعلومات التي تعود اصولها الى اختراع
التليجراف حتى اصبحت تمتلك حياه وموت هذه
الخطوط والتي يشبه وضعها وضع النفط في
نهايه القرن التاسع عشر استضيف للحديث عن
ذلك اول خبير تكنولوجي يحذر منذ سنوات من
انتهاء السياده على المعلومات السيد سونيل
تجاري احييكم اينما كنتم من العربيه انا
منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
عندما تقرا رساله بريد الكتروني او تشاهد
مقطع فيديو او تنشر صوره على احدى الشبكات
الاجتماعيه او تقوم بعمليه شراء عبر
الانترنت او تستشير محرك بحث باختصار
بمجرد استخدام الانترنت فمن المؤكد ان
المعلومات تمر او مرت بواسطه كيبل الياف
ضوئيه تحت سطح البحر هذه الخطوط التي تكثر
في قاع المحيطات والبحار حسب موقع تيليو
جيوغرافي تنقل 99% من البيانات الرقميه في
العالم هناك ايضا فرصه جيده لان يكون
الكابل الذي ينقل تلك الماده مملوكا لشركه
الفابيت المالكه وميتا الملكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام وواتساب وبدرجه اقل امازون
ومايكروسوفت وفيما تفضل ابل الاعتماد على
شركات خاصه نجح اصدقائها من كريات شركات
التكنولوجيا وجوجل وفيسبوك وامازون
ومايكروسوفت وفي اقل من 10 سنوات من
السيطره على قطاع كان يهيمن عليه كبار
المشغلين الدوليين سبعون بالمئه من مشاريع
كابلات الانترنت العابره للقارات خاصه عبر
المحيطين الهادي والاطلسي مدعومه من قبل
جوجل وفيسبوك الكابل يكلف ثلاث مئه مليون
يورو وهو مبلغ شهيد من عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات التي تملكها كبرى شركات
التكنولوجيا والفوائد منه ضخمه جدا اذ
يكفي ان الكابل الجديد لشركه جوجل والذي
يربط الولايات المتحده باسبانيا والمملكه
المتحده قادر على نقل ما يعادل المكتبه
الرقميه الكامله للكونجرس ثلاث مرات في
الثانيه
دفع ذلك بالطبع كبار الاخصائيين الى اطلاق
صيحه فزع متهمه كبرى شركات التكنولوجيا
بالاحتكار وجعل حياه الانترنت او موتها
بايديها اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بالسيد سونيل
تجاري ضيفنا في البعد الاخر لهذا الاسبوع
اهلا بك معنا سيد سونيل وباعتبارك اول من
اطلق صيحه فزع قبل سنوات بشان احتكار خطوط
الانترنت لو تشرح لنا كيف انتبهت الى هذا
الموضوع منذ البدايه
لو نظرنا في التاريخ فان جل الخطوط في
العالم او كلها كانت مملوكه لشركات
الاتصالات لقد كان هناك دائما تعاون بين
الدول المختلفه وبين حكوماتها يمكنني
القول انه قبل ثمانيه او عشره اعوام
تقريبا بدات كل من جوجل وميتا تنفقا على
هذا الميدان ثم اطلقت جوجل شبكتها التي
تمكنها من الامتلاك الكامل للخطوط وهذا
يضعنا امام حاله احتكار تشمل كل العالم
غالبيه هذه الخطوط لا تملك الشركات
المحليه والحكوميه اي دور فيها حتى لو مرت
عبر اراضيها وبحارها
ما خطوره ذلك يعني القضيه التي نناقشها هل
هناك امثله عن خطوط وعن تكلفتها غير عن
جوجل
الدكتور
شركات الاربعه الكبرى وخاصه مالكه جوجل
وفيسبوك
الفابيتا هي الملاك الاكبر ومؤخرا انضمت
اليهما امازون ومايكروسوفت بالمشاركه في
هذا الميدان
هل من الممكن عندما يتعلق الامر بالمحيط
الاطلسي هل مازال ممكن نشر كيبل او كوابل
من دون شركات البكتيك اللي تحدثنا عنها
مطلقا لا انه غير ممكن لا يهم فقط كابلات
المحيط والبحار ولكن في كل العالم انشاء
واي خط يتطلب المرور عبر واحده من شركات
البيج تك تك طيب انا حتى الان لم افهم
يعني فسر لي طالما كانت هذه الكابلات
مملوكه لشركات الاتصالات كيف استطعت جوجل
ان تسيطر على
المساله وتصبح لا لاعب رئيسي في هذه
الصناعه جوجل وغيرها من شركات البكتيك
اعتقد ان جزءا من المشكل يتعلق بشركه
الاتصالات داخل كل دوله
فلقوتها الصراع الحاد بينها وجد عمالقه
التكنولوجيا منفذا للدخول بينه جوجل
وميتاج على الصراع بين شركات الاتصالات
عبر لعبه شراء احدى الشركات المحليه بهدف
النفاذيه لدولتها
[موسيقى]
ما دام انه من الممكن دفع رسوم لاستخدام
هذه الكبلات ما الذي يجعل شركات كبرى
تستثمر بمبالغ خياليه في هذه الكبلات
عندما تنظرين في اجمالي فقي اي شركه
تكنولوجيا لانشاء خط ترين انه لا يمثل
شيئا من اجمالي ارباحها او اي موازنه
لاطلاق مركز معلومات مركز واحد للمعلومات
يتكلف مليارات الدولارات ولذلك فان امتلاك
خط ينقل البيانات لن يتطلب الا جزءا لا
يرى من كلفه المشروع كله لذلك فالاهم لهم
هو السيطره وكلما كانت هناك فرصه لهم
لمزيد احكام القبضه على الخطوط عريضه
النطاق فانهم لن يتوانوا عن انفاق المزيد
من الاموال
فكره السيطره والتحكم من المفترض ان تكون
تابعه للحكومات ما الذي يفسر تراجع
الحكومات عن الاستثمار في هذه الميادين
غالبيه ودول باعت قطاع الاتصالات
للمقاولين لانها رات فيه قابليه للربح
وبالتالي راينا الحكومات محكومه بمشاريع
ورؤى شركات الاتصالات التي لا تملكها من
اجل ضمان توفير الانترنت لمواطنيها
والانها نحن في وضع النرى فيه دوله واحده
هي التي تشرف على عمليه استخدام الانترنت
لان كل شركات التكنولوجيا تنتمي لهذه
الدوله ما جعل البعد السياسي اهم من مفهوم
المراقبه
هل ما الذي تخشاه اكثر من غيره
مثل ما قلت فانه عندما نرى مثل هذا الوضع
السياسي الغريب الذي يمر به العالم فانه
يتعين على كل دوله تتاكد من انها في حال
وجود اي ازمه فانها تحكم قبضتها فيما
يتعلق بالنفاذ الى الانترنت والاتصالات
عامه من وجهه نظري فانه من اولويات اي
حكومه الان ان تبدا بفرض التدخلها في
عمليه بناء الكابلات وفي الانترنت لضمان
انه مهما كان الوضع فان نفاذ مواطنها الى
الانترنت غير مهدد
[موسيقى]
هل لك ان تعطيني اسماء بعض الحكومات التي
تواصلت معك نعرف انه هذه السيطره حتى لو
كانت شركات خاصه الا انه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه رقم واحد التي تسيطر على هذه
الكابلات بشركاتها الخاصه او بالاستثمارات
فيها اي حكومات اخرى تواصلت معك فيك
تعطينا اسماء
نعم مثال ذلك الحكومه الهنديه فقد اقتنعت
بان هذا الامر يمثل مشكلا لذلك بدات تطلب
وراء الخبراء ومنهم انا للنظر في كيفيه
تغيير البرامج الكبرى القائمه فيما يتعلق
هذه هي المره الاولى التي تعلن فيها حكومه
انها على وعي بالمشكل وتطلب وراء الخبراء
والناس بما يجعلها تدفي على صناعه
الكابلات بعدا سياسيا عبر اعتمادها على
الذات فيما يتعلق بالانترنت الانترنت سيد
سونيل تا جاري ارجو ان تبقى معنا سنذهب
الى فاصل قصير نعود بعده لمتابعه هذا
الموضوع
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد وارحب مره اخرى
بضيفي السيد سونال تجاري وكنا نتحدث عن
خطوره السيطره على القبلات الممتده في
المحيطات والبحار كيبلات الانترنت واعود
لك سيتداري ارحب بك من جديد ودعني اسالك
عن
بنيه اللوغاريتمات اللي هي بفضل المعادلات
الحسابيه يمكن للمنصات عبر الانترنت اداء
وظائف تهم الشان العام في جزء من الثانيه
دون الاعتماد على اشراف سلطه حكوميه ما
الذي يعنيه هذا الا يمس هذا مبدا سياده
الدول كيف يمكن التعامل مع مثل هكذا
الموضوع
اعتقد انه تماما مثل ملف الغذاء الذي تنظر
الدول في كيفيه التحكم في برامجه بتخزين
كميه منه ينبغي عليها الى الانترنت وخطوط
النطاق العريض بمثل هذه المقاربه
الاستراتيجيه
ينبغي لها النظر في خطط تمكنها من التاكد
من نفاذ مواطنيها الى هذه الخدمه الحيويه
في حال النزاعات ومهما كانت الظروف فمن
ناحيه الانفاق على هذا الامر فهو بكل
تاكيدا لا يتكلف الكثير ولكنه من الناحيه
الحيويه مهم جدا لبقاء الدول والمحافظه
على متطلبات العيش بين مواطنيها وايضا
بينها وبين باقي العالم في عالم اليوم
يمكن للفرد ان لا يتناول وجبه غذاء مقابل
عدم التنازلي عن لحظه على الانترنت لذلك
فقد بات هذا الامر مهما جدا ويحظى
بالاولويه المطلقه لدى الحكومات التي
يتعين عليها التحرك بقوه على هذا الصعيد
لو ممكن ان تقدم لنا تصور عن كيف سيكون
الانترنت وميدان الاتصالات عموما بعد
سنوات لما يكتمل مشهد سيطره هذه الشركات
الكبرى على القطاع
اعتقد اننا بلغنا بالفعل نقطه لا عوده
التي من غير الممكن فيها تقريبا ان يتم
بناء خط من دون مشاركه واحده من شركات
عمالقه التكنولوجيا الاربعه عمليا وحتى
بحكم الامر الواقع اصبح ذلك في حكم الصعب
جدا واعتقد انه بات لزاما على الحكومات
الانخراط منذ الان وعدم اهدار الوقت في
هذا الملف للعب الدوري الذي تكون فيه
بمثابه المنطقه العازله التي تبدا الشركه
ببناء خطوطها ليس داخلها وانما بعد حدودها
طب في سؤال تقني لو سمحت نعلم انه جل
المعطيات يعني اذا صح هذا التفسير التي
يتم نقلها على الانترنت يتم تخزينها
بتبدا او تنتهي في خوادم داخلي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انا يعني هذا انه في
النهايه هناك حكومه يمكنها عرقله سيطره
على هذه الصناعه
هذا مؤكد هناك مفهوم جديد يطلق عليه توطين
البيانات اي بمعنى تاميمها وجعلها بمثابه
القطاع الذي لا يقل اهميه عن الجيش
والغذاء حيث تنظر والكثير من الدول في
كيفيه تحديد البيانات التي يمكن ان تغادر
وما نوع البيانات التي تنبغي معالجتها
داخلها وما البيانات التي لا ينبغي ان
تخرج من حدودها مثل بيانات مواطنيها
الماليه بل وحتى بعد البيانات المتعلقه
باعمالهم اليوميه واسلوب عيشهم فهي مهمه
جدا وينبغي للحكومات ان تحتفظ بها داخل
دولها
عاده كيف بيتم تنظيم قطاع الانترنت
وتعديله
البيانات هي النفط الجديد ما تمثله ربما
حتى يفوق التغييرات العميقه التي شهدها
العالم في اواخر القرن التاسع عشر وعلى كل
دوله ان تعالجها على اعتبار انها قطاع
حيوي لا يقبل المقايده او التقليل منه
وعليها ان تتعرف على برامج الشركات والدول
المختلفه في التعامل مع بيانات مواطنيها
للاعتبار منها وبناء مناهجها حولها اعتقد
انه حان الوقت لحكومه العالم للانخراط في
البيانات وتحديد نوع البيانات التي يمكن
اجازه خروجها والاخرى التي لا ينبغي لها
تجاوز مياهها الاقليميه لو
سالناهم كان للكابلات البحريه ان تكون
سلاح هيمنه استراتيجي برايك
مثل ما شرحت ذلك فان التوجه العالمي هو
الاعتماد على الذات الاكتفاء الذاتي الذي
يحكم الغذاء ويحكم الامن هو نفسه الذي
ينبغي ان ينطبق على هذا القطاع بحيث يشعر
اي مواطن في دولته بانه غير مقطوع عن
الارض ففي حال كانت الدوله مكتفيه ومعوله
على امكانياتها الذاتيه فحتى قطع العلاقه
معها لن يؤثر بها ولن يقود ذلك اداء
مهامها يتطلب ذلك توفر حد ادنى من البنيه
عبر كابلات النطاق العريض او الاتصالات
الدوليه ما يجعل الدوله في الظروف
المتقلبه مثل اليوم تضمن الارتباط
بالانترنت لجميع مواطنيها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انشا
لجنه اسمائها
تمتلكهم مهمتها الاساسيه حسب ما فهمنا
تعطيل اي خط بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين هل السبب برايك يتعلق
بالامن القومي الامريكي او بعدم السماح
لهون كونج بان تصبح القوه الماليه الاكبر
في العالم
لا اعرف ما اذا كان لي فريق تمتلكم
نيه تتعلق بهم كونغ اعرف ان هذا الفريق
شكله دونالد ترامب في خضم جدالهم الصين
وخاصه بشان تكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتطبيقات والذكاء وكل الشؤون الرقميه
لكن يمكنني ان اقول لك بكل ثقه ان الضرر
الذي لحق عده شركات امريكيه جاءها من
شركات الاتصال الامريكيه اكثر لا من
نظيراتها الصينيه وانها هي التي كانت عرضه
لانقطاعات اكثر من الشركات الاسيويه
ومؤخرا لاحظنا انه روسيا حولت مسار حركه
الانترنت في منطقه خييرسون الاوكرانيه
التي تسيطر عليها عسكريا بحيث تم قطعها
بشكل كامل عن الشبكه المركزيه للانترنت في
اوكرانيا وربطها عبر بنيتها التحتيه
للاتصالات هل يمكن ان نشاهد مثل هذه
القرارات تمتد الى دول اخرى
هذا ما قلته وهو دليل على ضروره ان تتعامل
الدول مع هذا الميدان من مقاربه حيويه
وكيف يمكنها ضمان الانترنت لمواطنين في كل
الظروف والاوقات العصيبه مثل الحرب
الروسيه
اعتقد ان
الفابيتا كانت ذكيتين جدا في هذا الملف
لان خطتهما تضمن لهما القبضه على الكابلات
بعد ان انشات غالبيه الخطوط الحاليه فضلا
عن خطتها الاستعراضيه الكبيره في السماء
وبعيدا عن المحيطات ما يشعل اكثر القضيه
لقد بلغت قبضه كلتيهما على كابلات العالم
في كل اجزاءه وانحائه حتى لو لم تكن لهما
اجازه النشاط في الدوله التي تمر بها
الكابلات من وجهه نظر قانونيه حتى وان
كانت تبدوان محل نقاش الا انهما عمليا هما
من تقرران في هذا الميدان وهما من تتحكمان
بكيفيه اقوى من الحكومات بحركه الانترنت
في الختام هل من نصيحه للحكومات
لمواجهه اي تعطيل في خدمه الانترنت مواجهه
هذه المعضله العالميه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يتعين على كل دوله وحكومه ان
تقوم بعمليه تدقيق ومراجعه واسعه لوضع
الانترنت لديها وبناء برامج جديده تضمن
لها الاعتماد الذاتي والضمانات الكافيه
والبنيه الضروريه الملائمه مثل الذي تم
اطلاقه في الهند مؤخرا تحت شعار الهند
المعتمده على الذات يؤمن ذلك البرنامج
للهند التحكم في مصيرها ومصير سكانها
الرقمي مهما كانت الظروف الدوليه وحتى
الداخليه التي تمر بها وبالمثل ينبغي على
كل دوله ان تحذوها هذا المثال بما يضمن
لها في حال اي طارئ قيامها بالمطلوب منها
من مهام اداريه وايضا ان تجهز نفسها
بالتشريعات وايضا ماليا ما يجعل مواطنيها
قادرين على العمل بالانترنت تحت اي ظرف
والمساله ليست فقط الدخول الانترنت اللي
هي هي السيطره على سياده الدول لا احد
يستغني عن الانترنت الان سيد سونيل تجاري
الخبير في التكنولوجيا شكرا جزيلا لك على
المشاركه معنا الف شكر
الى هنا انتهت حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر
يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]